oh man the PS2 how y'all still got an
active working PS2 that's what I'm
saying I'm out Sanders running back I'm
Michael Parsons linebacker rusher we
represent the Ring of Honor and we
bringing in players Tony G Randy Barry
Sanders Primetime LT no that's cool so
right now we playing Madden 98 I wasn't
even born yet I was only one years old
yeah
I don't even know how to cake as you
kicking no that's you
oh wow oh wow you gotta look at what
Barry's saying to see all the stuff that
they either do to these boys back then
the way he runs the ball is very dang I
don't think I'm running you're supposed
to use this just keep going backwards
yeah his running stage is very unique
oh yep
oh
yeah I'm getting the hang of this game
how do you throw the ball man
transition
[Music]
and now we're in 04 Madden 04 Vikings
versus Falcons my dad was actually huge
in Madden they used to have Madden
tournaments with like him and his
friends yep
thank you thank you thank you
we gotta try to get the ball to Randy
yep Randy
Randy
what Defender do you think could have
done the best job against Randy
the only one that's going to maximum
speeds they said Prime and Andy like if
they clocked them like how they clocked
today like they would have ran like 4-1
that was your first touchdown man locked
in bro I'm playing ultimate team matter
Ultimate Team could be the number one
best thing about Madden the thing I like
about you get to sell the players you
don't want buy someone new you have
seasons almost like franchises you could
buy packs to unblock people which is
pretty cool oh yep quick yep hey
assistant get that block Tony G Tony G
Stephan get off me hey miles if you had
to take a receiver of all time oh
there's some code receivers now like
that I really like yes sir Randy Randy
for sure but other than Randy Devonte
Adams yeah this is night and day from
May 98. oh my God let me show y'all
Someone Barry Sanders it's the best
player in the game I have that counter
watch the blocking
you loads that up yep yep if you had to
pick your Ring of Honor players the
prime mic Berry Jacob Rob Gronkowski
Randy and and Chris Carter yeah put
yourself in there oh I thought we was
doing Legends of course I'll put myself
in there I'm taking me LT that's gonna
be doing I'm taking Prime and Rivas
and then I think I'm gonna take Derek
Brooks for the Middle with that five
right there out there with the future I
think the only only matchup that's going
to be legit is going to be that DB and
receiver match up yeah we we got reasons
in prime time but I got Randy and we got
prime time we got Prime you got Randy my
guy
[Music]